on a five and a half second difference
between chuck clock and game clock
five on the 24 curry at three
rebound westbrook and the lakers quickly
call their final timeout with 7.3
seconds remaining
they'll advance the ball in the front
court
and have a chance to tie it and force
overtime
[Applause]
so of course the question we always ask
guys
do
the golden state warriors foul they've
got a lot of time 7.3 seconds
it's always a tricky situation but what
do you think well what complicates that
particularly for their warriors as we
just saw in the last free throw
is their lack of size
and they're not a good rebounding team
so i still would do it but
the warriors have a different
route they're just not big and they
don't rebound the ball well mark i would
certainly foul in this situation and not
hesitate at all understanding that boils
down to just securing the rebound off of
miss rico
we got the right habits to do that well
meanwhile these two teams throwing
haymakers at each other klay thompson
leading the way lakers playing some
inspired basketball on the road in a
game they trailed by 15 earlier
thompson magnificent but now the lakers
with a chance
i think it's very interesting that the
lakers have kept
anthony davis in the game when they need
a three
without either a wayne ellington or an
avery bradley
[Applause]
and they have to get it in bounds
obviously
because they're out of time out
and this is the side of the floor lebron
james loves that step back three so
something to watch for westbrook holding
westbrook to malik monk monk a couple of
dribbles kicks it out james james puts
up the shot won't go rebound reads but a
whistle and a foul
on curry
three-point shot
so curry arguing they have already used
their challenge
so cannot challenge it
as curry picks up the personal
and jim capers he signaled
three free throws he's now discussing it
with marat hogan whether it was before
[Applause]
and it was definitely before
before he got into the upward shooting
motion
well
he clearly discussed it with his
officials
[Applause]
and whether they didn't go conclusively
if he didn't the initial call on the
floor was in the active shooting so
james will shoot free throws
he's four of six tonight on the season
he's at 75 percent
there's still 2.4 seconds remaining
and he missed the first
grinnelli's gotta
hit the second and miss the third that's
the only option
this crowd is elected
and looney comes into the game for
rebounding purposes but they're still
small
i would think about putting dwight
howard in right now james has to wait
till the ball hits the rim
those on the lane
on the release that's when they can go
in
[Applause]
high one
takes the carom rebound porter had it
picked up by james
puts it up that's it golden state win
what a thriller tonight here in san
francisco
15.
well james took a totally different
approach the high arcing missed
never seen that before
he gets a great bounce
and if he could have gotten it cleanly
you would have had a look
i agree with what you said white howard
or deandre jordan into the ball game for
rebounding purposes but it worked out
for the lakers unfortunately ran out of
time and how about the hustle by steve
kerr getting out of the way so james
unable to hit the three free throws
porter did an excellent job tipping it
away from the basket
and steph curry and the warriors survive
they want klay thompson in his 14th game
back
with an absolute gem 33 points